kentaro miura's postmortem final chapter
of berserk has finally arrived none of
us know currently whether this is the
real end of berserk whether his editors
will pick it up but what we do know is
that this is mira's final chapter the
last memento from the creator of a
series that will forever be remembered
and i think
whether he meant for it to be or not
whether it is even the last chapter
it still served as an absolutely
beautiful closing sentiment to this long
long story
the chapter is short following the
ending of 363 the moonlight boy arrived
in elfheim in front of guts
and now guts brings the boy to casca
being their first time meeting since her
mind was even restored and we really get
to see even more here the almost
maternal bond that the boy shares with
kaska
it's nice to see that even if the
journey here with casco without her
memory was
tragic and steeped in horrors she still
retains that bond she had with the boy
over its duration
and after dropping off the boy gutz goes
to train as per usual really as expected
of cuts
only to see that his body still has yet
to fully recover from its lasting
injuries from the berserker armor he
drops his sword mid-swing his throwing
knife barely slices past its target guts
accepts that at this point in the story
he still can't reach his full potential
without the armor just another important
mention of gut's current state a very
important part of the recent chapters
and exploring the origin of the armor
and one thing that i thought was
particularly touching about this chapter
came right after
where not only did we see once again the
bond between kaska and the boy but the
bond between guts and the boy as well
it's been long known or at least
confirmed that the moonlight boy is the
misshapen son of guts and caska and out
of their very few encounters this time
we really see what is almost like a
paternal bond as well like a father and
son
this page as a whole almost feels like
that peace that gutz deserves that he's
been seeking over this long long journey
kaska's memory is restored he no longer
is fighting he has a family
and of course none of that is completely
true or completely perfect as nothing
really is in berserk as even though she
has her memory kaska still suffers from
ptsd he no longer has to fight because
well he physically can't right now and
having a family this is only a passing
moment where he looks like a father
but it just makes this chapter feel even
more like a perfect ending to miura and
guts's story
casco wakes up to see that the boy is no
longer with her and she watches out of
the window and we finally witness the
big reveal and something that has been
foreshadowed up until now
that the moonlight child is in fact
griffith
in chapter 358 we saw griffith noticing
his hair starting to darken and then he
disappeared from his chambers into the
night and coinciding with the recent
sighting of the boy in the last chapter
we now witness what we all kind of
expected as he transforms into griffith
and he says to us how on nights on full
moon
he becomes an infant he feels the
embrace of a familiar warmth
but as he awakens from that dream only a
faint feeling of loneliness remains but
that too even disappears in just a
moment
like a single teardrop just like the
morning dew
i really have no words to describe this
ending
not only because the line is so poetic
but also just because of how much of a
callback it is to what we've witnessed
in this story
it's the first time since griffith's
reincarnation has femto that we have
really witnessed him show emotions like
this let alone shedding a tear one of
the most significant embodiments of
feeling emotion
we of course know that on these full
moon nights the familiar warmth he feels
is kaska as he always visits them as the
moonlight child and to know that
griffith does still feel emotion and
sadness and a warmth towards kaska is
just another testament to the complexity
of this character and this story
perhaps what we always saw and thought
of as a maternal or paternal bond
between griffith guts and caska was in
fact the bond of old friends reuniting
in those short moments where griffith
changed into the boy he naturally always
returned to what remained of the band of
the hawk
but then again you must think it it
could all just be a facade that's the
great part about griffith and berserk in
general
is that all the characters especially
griffith are so multifaceted and complex
that
it's almost impossible to say for sure
what they are feeling
i also think that the simile comparing
these emotions to the morning dew is
just a work of art from miura morning
dew as an object is always associated
with not just purity but beginning a day
anew
a fresh beginning and beyond just the
comparison of that to a teardrop in the
chapter the comparison of griffith being
reborn in the light of a new day as a
knight in shining white pure armor is
another callback you can see
griffith is always associated with the
idea of purity and it's awesome to see
that even in his most saddening moments
even his emotions embody that idea
lunar eclipses also only occur during
full moons making another contrast
between the pure black of the eclipse
and griffith becoming femto and the full
moons where the moonlight boy appears a
symbol of rebirth and purity
i think in typical mira fashion just as
many questions that were answered there
are even more questions left to be had
at the ending the chapter itself doesn't
contain that much
but it's the small moments and lines
that really bring it together and call
back to the series and what miuta has
always been building towards
i think once again seeing griffith show
emotions and seeing the moonlight childs
connecting him to guts and kaska as a
friend one more time even if that
perfect vision of them being reunited as
the band of the hawk can and never will
actually happen
it's it's amazing
it's so touching as someone who has
spent so many years with this story it's
beautifully drawn and i once again would
like to thank kentaro miura for the
journey that he started
and the lasting memories that it will
leave us with
rest in peace
you